♪ The doctor said my parent
down said my life a fragile ♪
♪ Perfected in the game,
I guarantee the name ♪
♪ Just put your head down, do the work ♪
♪ And everything will Change sip the tea ♪
♪ Have the feel, just as what I wanted ♪
♪ Be a patient, held held the tricky ♪
♪ Tea with Garyvee,
reach your positivity ♪
- July 22nd 2020, super
fired up, big shout out
to my brave change Robert
Cloudy in the building.
Luchia chef what's good
Kelly Hill in the building.
Love tribe big shout out to
YouTube, Facebook, Periscope
I see you all Twitch
squad in the building.
Where's LinkedIn family
see a LinkedIn logo.
Leave your comment, leave
your comment good to see.
brought tap I really did
I hope as much as I have.
And I'm really excited for
Abel Franco, it's good man.
It's been really fun
having you part of this
if you've been following
every episode Abel, good.
Really good friend of mine
from Grammar and Middle School.
We relived some wrestling memories too.
So that was fun.
Really, really good to see all of you.
Now, the big question is
who's part of the Share Squad?
Who is part of the Share
Squad, who right now
is going to copy the
URL, hit the share link
in their ecosystem,
whether it's Twitch,
LinkedIn, Twitter, Facebook,
who is gonna take that URL and paste it
into a Facebook post or
LinkedIn post or Twitter post
or just hit the little Share button?
Let's get some new homeys in here.
If you have shared the URL right now
to your audience on social,
please leave hashtag Share Squad.
Lets see who else is in here,
Vicki Good to see you always.
Luke says "Hey guys," that
means he's from Australia.
Orlando Mackenzie, I
appreciate you on LinkedIn.
So much just hit shared.
I wanna give a shout out
to shared as a social.
Let's see what's going on with Gucci.
Everything's Gucci Bassy BOOM.
What's good Hanili, you're amazing.
Thank you for the love
big Fort Lauderdale.
What's up, chat share,
share, share, share,
share, share, share, share share,
Amanda Smith is part of the Share Squad.
New England Property Disposal
is part of the Shore Squad.
Dustin How are you?
- Great.
- Vipes Pokemon?
- Yeah I got two on the way.
- All right, lets share that.
- Everything's been sold out.
- I think I bought a red
Cheeks E3, giveaway promo
1999 PSA 10 last night.
- How much?
- Maybe 625 I think I got it for.
- Interesting.
It was a promo card
- On eBay?
- On eBay promo card
first year E3, Pikachu.
Yep, you missed it, I grabbed it.
I'm also going completely
ham on vintage basketball,
like just Dr. J on key Magic Bird.
Barkley Drexler, Ewing, Stockton,
Elgin Baylor, Jerry West,
going ham ham ham basketball.
Like am a ham sandwich.
(laughing)
all right, lets get into the show
- Garyvee what's up my man.
- What's good, Jaycee how are you?
- Hey, I'm really Gary,
this is an absolute pleasure, brother.
- Thank you where are you from?
- I'm from Perth, Australia, my man.
Yeah, the west coast of Australia, man.
- I know, it's beautiful there.
- Yeah, man.
It's crazy to actually be
talking to you right now, man.
This has been a big
manifestation, like three,
five years in the making.
Before we get into man I wanna
shout out my manager Julian.
He has to this event will happen.
He's talking to Andy Kay.
And Zane for some time so
big shout out to Julian
and Nick obviously.
- Of course.
- Yeah, my man.
I just what so I just start off man
and I just tell you a little bit about
- Yeah, can you say yeah,
give me some context,
give me the question.
- Yeah, so my name is
Jaycee, I'm an artist
independent artists
representing Australia.
I'm true to my music.
I'm passionate about my music.
And yeah, lots some examples
of what I've done last year
I put out 26 music
videos every single week.
Every song produced
mixed mastered by myself
dropped that every week.
And that was a Guinness Book world record.
I also every year like
following the Ross blueprint,
I've chopped songs every week
I've been on Tik Tok man,
I've got a following on Tik Tok,
thanks to you got me on to
that when the time was right.
I've got and now I'm in
this position now where
I've got fans building.
I've got half a million Tik Tok followers.
I've got, 20,000 Spotify listeners.
I've got labels now hitting me up.
Big major labels hitting me up
and I've got my songs on commercial radio
and I'm just like me and
the team we're thinking
what's the next move?
Where do we go from here?
- I think the next is to build
out a distribution network
that isn't just social media.
What I mean by that is, if I'm an artist,
and I've got everything that I
just heard you talking about,
the thing I'm thinking
about is how do I make sure
that more people hear it?
The next time I put something out,
and the way to do that is of
course, things like Tik Tok
or YouTube or Instagram.
But the other way to do that
is to actually spend 500 hours
as a team, reaching out to
every music blogger, every music
communicator like Mike Boyd on my team,
who puts playlists together,
reach out to 1000 playlist
Spotify playlist curators.
Reach out to 1000 music bloggers.
Reach out to 1000 Instagram music accounts
that share new stuff,
create one to one relationships
with distribution.
Reach out to 5000 YouTube
influencers and say,
"Yo, I would love to make
you some original music."
- Man
- Please.
- Yeah, yeah, and that's
funny that you say that cause
that's what we have
essentially been doing.
I didn't know to the extreme
of 1000, or whatever.
- It takes the extreme because
when you have a new song,
if you got 34, people,
only three are actually gonna put it out
because they got a bunch
of other shit going on.
They wanna write about something else,
they wanna do something else.
So I actually do think
it's to the extreme.
My big thing is, if you
wanna live your dream.
And this is for everybody
who's watching right now.
If you wanna live your dream,
how the fuck are you not going
to the extreme, and I mean, it.
It's like, it's kind of
like working out, right?
Like, I'm blown away
yesterday, Mike, my trainer,
I work out virtually with him every day.
And he had me doing this goblet squat.
And it was like 52.5 like max
weight on the Bowflex thing
that I had to order.
But the amount of reps he asked me doing,
he had me do one and a halfs.
And I just remember thinking, I was like,
I can't do this, and I did
it and I was like right.
Like if I wanna get healthier
if I wanna build muscle,
if I wanna build my core
and my legs so when I'm 85
I don't trip and that
starts the path to death.
Well, of course I've gotta
push myself to the extreme.
If you're an artist, if you're
somebody who's tryna make it,
become famous, become an
influencer, make a million dollars,
all these crazy things that
come outta people's mouths.
I actually think Jaycee like
I'm excited, we're together.
It's like, no, no no it's a 1000.
- I completely agree with you,
Gary, I am all about that.
It's the same way, I watched
every single Rose interview
I've watched Oliyo, Garyvee.
- You must have loved when
Rose was on my podcast
that must have been one of your favorite.
- Oo man, that's what did it
I saw that and I saw the song "Awake"
I'm a huge Rose fan, I
produce all this stuff
and that's what did it we
had the same conversation
and I was like, I want to
do a song "Awake" as well.
And that's what did I know it
was a big learning curve man
because it goes to really test
you and it really goes back
to what are your
intentions behind doing it.
For me, I did the song "Awake"
and my results weren't like
one blew up one did this,
it was a really humbled me
and man you realize that
it's really about the
music and it's really about
the love and the passion
of what's your intention,
what are you trying to bring to the world?
- Jaycee, I really, I
really, really, really,
really believe that the
number one you think that you
and team have to figure
out is more distribution.
- Okay
- Period.
- Right
- Like what I honestly you wanna do,
everybody's watching wanna
do something interesting.
Go type in my name on YouTube,
and search, least views.
- Right?
- Go watch how much shit
I've done for how long?
- This is actually written like,
this is really relevant
because I was like,
we actually had a discussion last night
cause we're in the middle between putting.
We don't know whether to put it all out
and then have it our flaws out there
and our perfections out there.
- Yes, that, that, that, that
don't even debate no more
imperfections out, imperfections out.
Other thing I would look very heavily
into video game culture.
I would hit up a ton of Twitch streamers
try to win that eSports video game culture
that's a real sport.
- Right, right.
Okay, sweet also Gary I
wanna say thank you for
the following Tik Tok my guy.
I don't know if that was you who did
- That was me.
- So you watching, are you watching?
- I'm the only one who
controls who I follow.
I'm the only there's a reason
there's a team Garyvee account
so that they can do those things.
I, everything That's Garyvee.
I write, I follow I live, it's me.
Alright, Jaycee I'm gonna
run because I got a bunch
of people coming on, love you men
keep pushing it.
- Thank you
- Follow Jaycee everyone,
take care, moving.
- What's up old friends?
- What's up old friends Tamar.
So listen, everybody, I was
gonna do a podcast this week
and bring together notice
that Tamar said "old friend."
We've known from day one Twitter,
we're talking OG life, when
there was like me and her
and like 5000 people on
Twitter, early Twitter,
and we were catching up.
She's doing something
incredible that I've been,
like really passionate
about that she's up to.
And we were just catching
up on Zoom last week,
And it's Tamar you know
what, I'm gonna do a podcast
and get four or five old friends together
do an old friend show.
Unfortunately, I just got a
little sidetrack with my biz.
So last night, big shout out
Tamar to always stay persistent
cause I'm busy, I'm chaotic.
My intent is there
but I'm getting hit by
baseballs left and right.
She hits up yesterday like
"hey, my fundraising for my"
and I'll let her explain it.
And I was like fuck cool,
let's get you on with Tea
with Garyvee so Tamar do me
a favor, A, tell everybody
what you're up to because
I want everybody supporting
and Dustin pay attention to the URL
or this is probably good
cause you can share it all
on Twitter after but I
think a lot of you're
gonna be blown, yeah, that's
too long of an iPhone me.
So let's put her Twitter handle and Tamar
after you're done here, put the links up.
If you love me in any way.
This is a real OG friend of mine.
Please go contribute a
little bit to her project.
Wait to hear what it is,
Tamar tell em what it is.
- Yeah, yeah thank you so much.
All right so first of all, yeah,
I've known Garyvee since
the early early tech days.
I was working in tech and
marketing for over a decade
and didn't realize when Gary
basically had his first kid.
I had my own first kid and I
had a postpartum depression.
For lasting for nine years.
I hit a rock bottom in 2018.
I was not in a good place, woke
up went through the motions.
That was my life.
One day, I found a little
vial of perfume in a cabinet
and when you're depressed you
don't care what you look like.
I certainly didn't you
definitely don't care
what you smell like and the thing is,
most people put on
perfume with no objective
but to like smell good for other people.
But that obviously wasn't me.
I didn't give I didn't
care about my share.
And that was life changing for me.
I don't really know exactly what it was.
But it was an impetus to
start living my life again.
And I decided I was going to do something
in this perfume world.
I started studying scents reading books.
Consuming all the media possible,
joining all the communities
wherever I could possibly be.
And I said, you know what,
I'm gonna start a brand
called Tamar, Tamar.com,
and with the objective of making perfume,
have basically happiness in a bottle.
And I was crazy, but I launched,
did a soft launch in May.
And I'm still in the middle
of this fundraising right now.
Because right now is the right time.
Thinking about I mean, it's
the worst time financially
but at the same time, we
don't feel good for ourselves.
Right now we're stuck at home.
We don't love ourselves
and this little thing
that you could do and revisit this,
sniffing your wrist throughout the day,
it can actually change you
and make you feel better.
So that's my story.
I'm in the middle of fundraising for this.
- Everybody when I
think about self esteem,
it is the only thing I kind
of have most care about
because it leads to happiness,
which then leads to kindness for others.
When Tamar was telling me scent
drove this reality for her,
it just really hit me
like a ton of bricks.
And it was about doing it for
you instead of doing it for
someone else, hit me like a ton of bricks.
So it's a dear friend,
please, please, please
go to Tamar.com but also,
Tamar do me a favor,
cause I know you're @tamar on Twitter,
please put up links to your
funding page right now.
I would love the Vayner
Nation to give a little love.
I've done my part please do
a little bit of your part.
I love you keep pushing this story.
I think there's something Tamar,
I really believe you'll be
historically correct about this.
Cause after you told
me, I did some homework.
It's fucking fascinating.
- Yeah, yeah, thank you,
so if you go to Tamar.com,
there's actually a link
that you wanna learn
about the campaign.
That's live ends on 7.31,
so that's next Friday.
So your support is definitely appreciated.
Thank you so much Gary, I
really, really appreciate it.
- And everybody go hit up Tamar right now
with further questions or his and hellos.
Like everybody, go to
your Twitter right now
and just say what's up Tamar
especially if you're interested
in this project so that
she can engage with you
on Twitter for the rest of the day.
Awesome love you, talk to you soon.
- Love you too, take care.
- I wanna do, Dustin I
wanna do more of that.
I wanna do a little bit more
of like sneaking in like
one person just giving love
touring Tea with Garyvee.
What do you think?
- Yeah, I thought the same.
- Its just nice, right?
- Yeah,
But I want it be authentic
to me, not the team for like,
the team needs to remind me to like,
What inspired you today?
Who do you wanna help
today instead of like,
we pick this person
cause I don't wanna be
Zane's fucking thing
that inspired Zane.
- I think we have a good
understanding of that (chuckles).
It's for you, not for us.
- No, no, no, I wanna pick it.
- All right, just let us know, we got it.
- I will, lets keep moving.
Dustin what's good.
- What's going on, man?
- Life is good, you.
- Oh, it's going great.
- Good
- First off, I've got to say I mean,
thank you so much for
everything you've done.
I started my YouTube
channel about 100 days ago,
mainly focused around
collectibles investing,
sports card investing, slash collecting.
We get in all things,
action figures and video
games and all that stuff.
I think it's all cool.
- By the way that the two
categories action figures
and video games that I
collected in between and flipped
in between my 1993 and my
two years ago, sports cards,
me and AJ's Garage selling
was 80% toys and video games.
- Really
- AJ and I were so right
about video games, we were
buying Nintendo cartridges
for a quarter at Garage
Sales and Yard Sales.
A piece maybe a dollar but only if it
was contra Mike Tyson's "Punch Out"
and "Zelda" and "Mario's"
in like 2002 to 2003 action.
We crushed wrestling
figures we crushed I mean,
at that point, even today
2002 three it was hard to find
"Transformers GI" Joe's
"Star Wars," but we would.
But I probably am as
knowledgeable about action,
I mean I know more about Mego
Star like superhero stuff.
Like I mean the amount I know about LGNs
and Hasbro wrestling
figures I know ThunderCats
and like I know that space extremely well.
- The best yeah get the
ThunderCats figures there.
- I know video game, I know
Atari 2600 like crazy climber
was a male away act cartridge
like I know Paper Mario
like I know my shit.
- Yeah,
- I'm sneakier about
knowledge that people realize.
- Well part of my channel
is kinda going back
to my childhood and the nostalgia
and it's maybe it's part
of the midlife crisis
thing I'm approaching 40.
- Its not midlife crisis, it's happiness.
- It really is, yeah.
- Midlife crisis is like doing
selfish shit that like fuck
no, no, this is happiness.
- That's what I told my wife like.
- The sports cards thing is fucking crazy.
I just gotta a mail package,
why don't you tell everybody about you,
I'm gonna go to my package
and share with you all,
cause I don't get to share what I like,
cause now you're like,
post shit because like,
the price goes up and everybody gets mad.
But in this environment,
I'm gonna just share
what I just got but why
don't you tell everybody
a little about that, and then
I wanna hear your question.
- Yeah, so I started
out about 100 days ago.
I've created 160 plus videos
on YouTube on my channel,
the Personal Finance Dad.
And it's all around kind of
getting back into the hobby.
I got back in about two years ago,
after about a 25 year
hiatus I started collecting
in the late 80s, early 90s.
Like a lot of my peers that can relate
and so just kinda getting back into it,
going back to my childhood.
Started creating content
really having fun with it,
and then it kind of,
segued into other things
like video games and comic books.
And now we just kinda gone
from there but yeah know,
it's been a great time and
it's a great community.
It's amazing how many people
are getting back into it.
Or just people that are
new getting into it.
It's wild so not sure what
else to say but actually I
and Gary's talking about a mail day thing
I got a package I got a letter
from a kid a 12-year old
that sold me something
on eBay that said, "hey."
It was a handwritten note
from a 12-year old that said,
"thank you very much for your
purchase, we appreciate it"
and reminded me of when
I was 10 years old,
except I didn't have eBay
and didn't have all these
options to buy singles online.
So it was just, it was
refreshing so it just shows you
kind of all generations.
- The hobby is exploding,
and the happiness is absurd.
Dustin, get in here, let's tell.
Like Dustin, Dustin, like,
Dustin how much happiness has getting
into collecting Pokemon and
flipping Pokemon been for you?
- It's been surprisingly fun.
Like I thought it'd be stupid
at first, but now I'm kinda
like really Like, yeah,
because I feel like I guess
I'm learning a skill in a way like.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, Yeah.
There's a lot of business
in negotiation behind it.
I mean, I was saying
to you like when I was
eight years old
- Yeah go ahead,
- When I was eight years
old, I was battling with,
local card shop owners
trying to negotiate out
that was my first foray
into business negotiation.
It's trying to buy cards at the local LCS.
- Are you kidding me?
Like, of course, I'm
like, when people like,
you're like, you're savant,
I'm like, no, I'm well trained.
I've been doing this every day.
Like, it's no, it's a huge, huge thing.
And it's, listen,
there's nothing more fun
than to have a ton of fun.
And it makes you money
versus it costs you money.
- Yeah.
- Most things that are super
fucking fun, cost money.
- Yeah.
- Spending two hours searching
on eBay when what's going on,
and like trying to find
that diamond in the rough
and the data and you have fun with it.
You're gonna make it money
doing that versus watching
something on Hulu that
you paid a subscription
for to be entertained.
You're being entertained,
to learn, and to have fun.
And most of all, it makes money right?
Listen, there are tens of
millions of people out of a job.
We are completely being
disguised by COVID.
Our government is just printing money
to throw at the problem.
Like the economy is going
to get punched in the face.
Like understanding how
to make money right now.
I've had over 25 people literally,
25 is a big number with
what I'm about to say
cause I've been counting it.
Say that through DM and email
that card flipping has
fundamentally allowed their family
to not be in a shitty
situation during this time.
And have they not heard me
in October, November,
January last year, do it,
like they would be they lost their job,
and like they're paying
their rent and eating.
Like emotional shit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- On the record for anybody's
watching, markets go down.
And also there's some level of gambling.
Let me give an example.
One of the things I'm most
interested in is in gambling.
So football is coming up
obviously I love watching this
but when the Panthers
are playing the Packers,
I don't give a shit, and I don't gamble.
But now this year when the
Panthers play the Packers,
I'm gonna care because I
have this weird feeling
that Teddy Bridgewater is
gonna have a good year.
And he's the starting
quarterback and Carolina.
And this is like fun for me
now, because like buying these
and if he has a good year, boom
or the then there's like other stuff.
So like this one, like this
just means a lot to me.
Willis Reed is one of the
Greatest Knicks of all time.
This is a almost perfect
card SGC 9.5 from a 1969 set.
Think about how old that is.
Yeah, it's one of the great Knicks right
so like, that's fun.
I bought this, this was
super interesting to me.
These massey stickers were
super cheap six months ago.
- Yeah.
And he's obviously and
I think soccer cards
are just and stickers are gonna be some
of the most expensive stuff.
And they weren't like one
of the most important things
is a weird little set, it
wasn't like the big one.
But these have gone from
like 80 to like 600 bucks
in like a couple months, I
was right because it's massey
it's so for and PSA 10 right.
And then my favorite thing old basketball,
these aren't even in great shape.
These are literally from a hotdog company.
Literally, literally from cons
the winner that the world,
look at this thing.
Dustin that's funny to you,
you like Wiener you're looking
at it Dustin (laughing).
And then obviously like these are two
of the most iconic players
of all time, Oscar Robertson,
literally Jerry West is the
logo on the fucking jersey.
- Yeah.
- So like, that's why it's fun.
That was my little stash that came in.
- That's awesome, man, that is awesome.
Yeah, the first question
I wanna ask you is so
a lot of folks have and this has caught
the mainstream attention, we've seen this
but recently LeBron, RPA
sold for record $1.8 million.
I guess my question is just
from your opinion on it.
Do you see more or any I
don't have any insight,
institutional money coming in.
This was something that
happened 15, 20 years ago
with coins with rare coins, and you saw,
I mean, pricing just
went through the roof.
- Well, tell me about that.
Educate me, Dustin,
because the answer is yes.
I believe that, there is a
stunning amount of real money,
institutional money coming in.
I know people that have been approached
that are on Wall Street by others.
I've heard of conversations
I've been asked
for my information of
what I see what I know.
Yes, do I believe like,
do I believe 100 million
dollars of five to 15
to 30 groups comes into
the sports card world
and starts buying up super
premium stuff because this is
this generations art, yes, I do.
I think that a 52-year old
high net worth individual
from New York wants to
remember or maybe 60 year old
that wants to remember
that Knicks championship
cause we've sucked for so
long that this one of the
only perfectly graded Willis Reed cards
is actually worth 20 times
what it's worth right now.
The second New York money
comes in, yes, I believe that.
- Right, yeah.
- And that's not me promote,
like, I get so frustrated
when people like Garyvee
like, yes, I have an audience.
And I'm sure I brought
in a lot of awareness.
But this was so first of all,
the only reason I've loved
card since I was eight.
I've been I've had notoriety
and awareness for a decade.
I didn't talk about cards,
cause it wasn't happening.
- Right, yeah.
- I'm talking about it
cause it's happening,
but the answer is yes,
I do believe that's happening.
Now my question to you is,
I've not educated myself on.
I know that the coin
markets a much bigger market
than the card market, which makes no sense
because nobody under 50
gives a fuck about coins,
and everybody and a shocking
amount under 50 care
about cards, but I'm not
educated on what happened to
that scarcely am more educated
on what happened with art
in the turn of the century?
Educate me a little bit,
what do about that point,
- My knowledge is very basic,
that was just something
that as I was doing research
I saw a graph of it where
literally institutional money
got into rare coins, and it's shot
through the absolute roof,
and then within kinda of a
two year period it started to.
It did come down, but it did
create kind of a new floor,
for rare coins, and that's the thing.
- The answer is yes, so I wanna
move on to other subjects.
But the answer is absolutely, yes.
I think that this is early,
the economy could collapse
and people may not look
for alternative investments
that could change things.
Markets go up and down.
There's Teddy Bridgewater
can get benched in week two
and like, that's why I
don't really buy new stuff.
This is more to entertain me.
But this stuff.
This and the global icons
that have already made it,
they are absolutely no brainers to me.
Next question.
What types of innovations
would you like to see
that could advance the hobby?
- There's only one big one
the machines that come along
that great cards instead of humans.
- Yeah, when AI technology,
when that comes,
it's gonna go through the roof.
- That's huge
- But the way,
humans judge antiques and art now.
- Yeah.
- So like, let's not forget that.
So anyway, I gotta move on,
Dustin love you pal, talk soon.
- Thanks very much.
- They'll be a card only show.
We'll make sure we get you back on.
- I love it, thanks, Gary.
- Thank you bye.
Ambishee, when you say how there
you card greeting as an art?
I'm a big fan, I just think
that technology will help it
because a lot of people are
concerned about the human
aspects of grading where
people manipulate and things of
that nature and that's always
a tension like it is in any
other human based objective world and so
I do think that technology will come
and that's not my opinion
that's just knowing
the advancements of technology
that will eventually get
there, let's keep moving.
Hi, Gary, good morning?
- Hey Andrea how are you?
- How are you, thank you for your time.
Thank you for doing Tea with Garyvee.
- You're welcome real quick.
Everybody's watching Share Squad time.
It Shares Squad time,
Andrea do this with me.
Share, share, share, share,
share, share, share, share,
everybody share if
you're watching go ahead.
What's your question?
- Okay, so quick story.
Quick background, I work
in the live event industry.
So in February of this year,
I decided to started doing my own shows.
I go on my own, producing my
own projects keep thriving.
In January of this
year, I became pregnant.
- Congratulations
- Thank you.
So then however, March came COVID came?
And then of course,
I mean, the majority of the
events that I had confirmed
or whether they were
rescheduled or canceled yeah,
- Trust me, I know, mo of my
money comes from speaking.
All gone, so its zero, so
it's been an intense time.
- So and also the uncertainty as well.
So, but however, I mean, I've
been working on new things
and then one of the things
that I've been working is wood working.
- Okay,
- Well basically,
by the way, I've never
worked with wood before
like curve anything.
So I started carving out
kitchen utensils out of wood
all of a sudden, and
then I really enjoyed it.
I do see a big vision in
it, like in the near future,
but however I'm still
learning in order for me
to sell it out to the public
and then provide this product
up in the near future.
So that's one thing, I mean,
this is the one of the spatulas
that I've done.
- So cool, good for you.
- Thank you.
- I'm really proud of you. I
think a lot of people during,
COVID exposed a lot of things,
where a lot of people had
something bad happened like
live events or restaurants.
They fell into a huddle
and cried and other people
just attacked something
else and innovated.
I'm just really impressed by
your will and your creativity.
- Thank you, yeah, I mean,
it's been a roller coaster
I mean just dealing with so many emotions
and also the pregnancy and everything.
- Of course.
- But however additionally, I
work with a production company
called Miss Dieser production.
Before COVID we work a live
entertainment production company
making audiovisual
performances for live I mean
social events corporate, so on.
And I mean, we build entertainment
for purposes of brands,
product promotional products,
and so on and so forth.
So, with this is through life, talent,
drums, percussion musicians,
and however we've been pivoting
and taking these elements and
then providing the service
to virtual events, the virtual
events that are happening
right now making it more
engaging, more interactive.
- You're becoming a production
company in the reality
of a digital virtual world
instead of a physical one.
- Exactly so, however, I
mean, we're still tryna learn
how can we do all these
performances with the musicians
with the dancers, with the recording,
because it's pre recorded, and then yes,
so basically just providing
the service to all the clients
that we have or new and clients.
And basically just making
it more of a solution
or making it more
interactive with the audience
like something because you're sitting down
and then on the computer and
then just with the conference
and making more interactive.
So my question to you
is my whole question,
how would seeing all this,
how would you manage,
whether it's the woodworking, the pivoting
and the online events.
- I got it, I've a huge answer for you.
The number one thing that
you need to think about
is not over judging
yourself on a daily weekly
or monthly basis.
- Yes (chuckles)
- I love every single thing
that came out of your mouth.
- Thank you so much.
- You are trying, you're
ambitious, you're thoughtful.
The number one vulnerability you have
is over judging yourself.
- Yeah, yeah, and it has
been, I mean, it's also
like all the struggling also
because of the pregnancy
and then you have to feel good.
And then in order for you to
cause you're carrying a living
person inside of you, so.
- I've heard.
- But anyhow, I mean, that's...
- Please listen to this.
It's the number one part.
- Yeah
- Everything I've heard is phenomenal.
It's going to be great
thing and the only thing
that you have to do is
say don't allow yourself
to say I should have done more or fuck
I should have, the words "I should have"
are literally the worst combo
of words that I can think of
for most people cause it
leads to deep anxiety.
It leads to anxiousness,
it leads to sadness,
which then leads, which then
leads to people not being nice
to other people, you know who's not nice?
People that are hurting.
And do you know how one gets hurt?
They over judge themselves,
they decide they're a bad person
without realizing they're
actually hurt person
and are wonderful but just are hurt.
They decide that the world is unfair
because they weren't lucky
enough to have work ethic
and they just aren't entitled
and think everything should come to them.
You are fucking killing
it with your energy.
I want you to first be you should,
like my hope for you
without knowing you is
for you to enjoy this pregnancy.
- Thanks so much.
- Its so special.
Its so special, I want you
to know that everything
is gonna be okay when you
have this kind of energy
and this kind of ambition,
and this kind of creativity.
It's all gonna be okay.
I want you to know you have
time I left my family business
at 34 years old with nothing.
I didn't have any net worth.
I started VaynerMedia
in the conference room
of another company, cause I
had no money to pay for rent.
I didn't judge myself, like,
oh, that was stupid to build
that business for my family.
It was, it made me proud.
I was 34.
- Wow.
- I was 34 years old.
I had saved a lot of money in my 20s
but I just put that into
Facebook and Twitter
cause I thought it was gonna
work and guess what it did.
And so I didn't have money, I was 34.
I was 34 and couldn't and
had no business and no VaynerMedia.
Had no notoriety had no speaking career,
had not written a book.
Got no, had made zero dollars in speaking.
And I was pumped because
I knew I had talent.
I knew that I had ambition.
And I knew I had time,
and when I see LeeJPlummer
in the comments right now
say I feel good at that.
"This makes me good at
35" how old are you?
- Me, 32.
You've unlimited time?
- (Laughs) Yes.
- 32, 33, 34, 41 I'm 44
right now and I fucking
when I tell you I feel so young.
I don't think I've even started.
As everything that's happening.
I don't think the distance
between where I'm at now to get
to this ownership is very far.
And I'm not crippled by it.
Because I'm just starting.
Yeah, people in the comments
right now that are 27, 29,
29 is a fucked up age cause
everyone's like, "oh 30"
and all, society.
Society has made a huge mistake in the way
that we taught people about age.
I mean, I'm interacting
with 63 year olds that
are just realizing that they're
leaving corporate America,
starting their own business
and they've never been
more alive and they're 63.
And healthy and vibrant,
and acting like they're 42
from a generation earlier
cause we're all younger,
we're eating better, we're
taking care of ourselves more.
The only mistake you can
make is beating yourself up.
You've got everything.
Should you do more woodwork, maybe.
Should you learn more
about workshop, maybe.
Do I think virtual events
are gonna be huge forever?
Yes, I do, and I think you
should double down on that.
But the number one thing you need to do
is enjoy this pregnancy.
Because it's extremely special
and wood work and production
and business and fucking
money and we'll all be there.
- Okay.
- Enjoy it, don't beat yourself up.
This is not to be stressed.
- Yeah, I mean, it's, of
course it's been (sighs).
It's been a roller coaster.
- It's always, it could also
listen, everyone's like,
it's a rollercoaster,
it's so intense, cool.
Let's role play in two years
from now COVID it's all set.
We're back to normal.
And then your best friend
dies of cancer and then
your government has an
election and goes to fascism
and then your partners
dies of a heart attack
and then your child gets
diagnosed with a disease.
Life is always.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Do you that if COVID
started three months earlier,
Kobe Bryant would be alive.
- Yeah.
Life was super fine in January in America.
If COVID started in December,
Kobe wouldn't be in that helicopter.
He'd be alive for another 60
years, life is unpredictable.
- It is.
- So do many people's
lives were saved by COVID
because their destiny
was to be on a highway
and get into an accident that
night but they were stuck
at home complaining that they're bored.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
People don't understand life.
- We need a better perspective.
You are so lucky, you're lucky.
You know women right now are
crying every day in their sleep
because they can't get pregnant.
- Yes, I mean, I've thought
of that about that every day.
I mean
- I believe you.
I'm not saying you don't
I am talking to theo audience right now.
Like, be grateful for what you have.
Be grateful for what you
have instead of stressed
about what isn't going well.
Every day, I have thousands of things,
hundreds of things tens
of things not going well.
I run a huge company, there's
unlimited things going on.
I have a big personality,
there's always hate being thrown out.
Like, I can't dwell on that,
I have to be too grateful
for the health of the
people I love, the end.
Gratitude is the formula.
- It is.
- So one long winded answer
for the right answer for you
is don't beat yourself up,
you are clearly, clearly
a fortunate person with
the right ingredients
to figure it out.
- Thank you so much.
- Enjoy this.
Figure out how to enjoy this.
enjoy, there's so many kids
complaining that they're at home
with their parents, and
this is the last chapter
that they're ever gonna have
meaningfully with their parents
before their parents die
and they're not enjoying it,
they're complaining about it.
- Yes.
- And in three years they're
gonna cry like a baby.
Looking back to the six months
they were at their parents
house during COVID.
And wish they played more board games
and wish they did come downstairs
and watch TV with their mom.
Like people take shit
for granted out here.
- Yeah, yeah, and things like this.
I mean, it's weather, I mean,
sometimes I just think about
the future but then sometimes
I am like grateful like,
"Oh my God, thank you so much."
It's given me more time to just sit down
and just be with my baby
and then just the pregnancy.
- By the way, I respect
the shit out of you.
I do the same, I love that you
have a thought to the future.
You have to strategize, it's good.
But it can't cripple you, and most of all,
you have to recognize
you're just a human being.
You're doing the best you can.
- Yes.
- Awesome.
- okay, thank you so much.
- You welcome.
Let's keep it going,
It's sure is Kat Heart.
- Garyvee.
What's good, Shawn?
- What's good, bro?
- I like the hat.
- (laughs) Thank you.
Yours too man, but bro Gary, you changed
my fucking life man.
Like both like financially
and like mentally.
And like I got a story
that I think is gonna like,
impact like everyone listening right now.
So, last June,
I started watching your
Garage Sale videos.
- okay?
- I'm like, "fuck, I can do that shit."
And at the time, bro, I only
had $50 in my bank account, $50
- Did you have debt?
- Yeah, cause I'm a college student.
So I had a part time job so
I was like still doing shit.
but I was still doing it all the time.
- So you've 50 bucks, you see the video
and you're like, "fuck, that's
not investing in Facebook
"and Twitter, that's sort
of VaynerMedia, that's not.
"That's something I can do."
Shawn I don't wanna get emotional.
But the single reason I did that show
was for what you just said.
I'm so happy, and I think the
world is so abundant that the
only fucking thing I want right now,
the only thing that like the
true thing that drives me
is to help people get happy.
And I came from dirt bro.
- Same bro.
- I wasn't given shit.
- Yeah.
- Like, and I fucking
figured it out with humility
and fucking work ethic and
education and trash talk
is education so keep going.
You've got me until,
so you see it, you like
"fuck, I can do that, I got 50
fucking dollars," keep going.
- So I started going to Garage Sales
first like Thrift Stores.
And I buy shit for a dollar
and like I'd even like sell it
for like two or three dollars.
- On what, Craigslist,
Facebook Marketplace
because two, three dollars
but on eBay with fees and shipping like,
how did you make that work.
- In eBay, but I was like,
slowly like build it up.
- You were just learning
even if you made 50 cents
you were learning, you were learning,
even if you lost money where
the shipping cost you more
than you thought it was kind
of okay, cause you were like,
fuck I'm learning.
- Yeah, and plus that like
builds up your feedback
and like it helps other
stuff build up eBay too.
And yeah, I think just
like anyone can do that,
cause I only had $50 in my bank account,
I was still working a part time job.
And other people can do that too.
And like the other like
inspirational thing is like,
I'm also a college
student and I was working
this past school year, I
was working three times,
three part time jobs, plus
a full time college student.
And so like the whole
thing, like people say,
"Oh, I don't have time."
It's like, that proves it wrong.
Like three part time jobs.
- Bro everybody has time.
People literally reply to
me during feeds like this.
I don't have time while watching me.
The fuck are you watching
me if you don't have time?
- Yeah you gotta do it men.
- I didn't watch Garyvee when I was a kid.
Like, it's like I wouldn't want shit.
I be doing nothing, nonetheless tell
give me some highlights stories.
Like so now you're doing it
what was your first breakthrough?
What was the first thing you bought cheap
and made some real money and you're like,
"yo, this is fucking different."
- I bought like this little
Einsteins plane thing
and have like all the
figures and everything.
So it's like complete
for $5 at Thrift Store.
And I sold it for 100 on eBay.
I'm like, "fuck, dude," I'm
just stupid like that you know.
And like, you just keep
learning and learning
and learning bro, and shit gets better.
And like, bro, this last
month, I just did 10K in sales.
And I started with 50
in my bank account, bro.
Like, and the thing is,
anyone can do this shit.
- I know, the fuck he's
talking about out here.
- Yeah, So I really want
- I have a whole generation
of guys and girls watching me
who love gambling on sports.
When this is happening you need a high,
you need an extra high to watch sports
cause you love it so much,
don't you gamble on the Panthers,
gamble on their quarterback.
If he sucks, it goes down 20%,
if he's right it goes up 500%.
- Yeah.
- Instead of like 50,
50 of losing all of it.
- Yeah, you gotta take that risk.
So like, I really want people
like to go follow my Instagram
that I've linked, right here.
- Okay, go ahead.
- I really I wanna show people,
that they can do this too.
And cause I know like, there's
a college student out there,
that mom out there that's
struggling to put like food
on the table next week.
And am like, you can do
this shit like 15 minutes.
- So bro, I'm looking at your content.
You need to do more how to cause
I'm looking at it right now
its more highlight reel.
- Yeah.
- And what you really need to do is like
if you want people to follow
you and I get the flex
of like having more followers,
and you're at 99 now from 260
and I'm sure I'll go to a
1000 real quick here, Mike.
but if you're gonna keep them,
you gotta give them value
and like, this is great and
it shows that it's true.
But you gotta do what I do the reason,
your trash will cost me
money DeRock's not free.
My team, I'm producing not
free, my time is not free.
But I'm showing them so you need
to really really really show
them like real and educate them
make video I see you
getting Twitch card flip.
How much did you pay for this Trae Young
that you sold for 338?
- Like 200.
- Dude, the sports card
thing has been crazy, huh?
- Yeah, and I got to Lukas
back in February, bro.
When you were talking about it.
- When I was talking about
it, what you pay for it?
- 250, now they like almost 1000 bro.
- Well its happening listen,
it's fucking happening
out here, and by the
way, cards could go down
but Garage Sales, they're
buying for dollars
selling for, that shit
never going anywhere.
- Yeah so please, everyone,
if you're watching
like please go follow it because
it'll make me wanna go even harder.
Like really helped me,
push myself to go so big.
- Hear me, hear me, hear me real quick.
It can't be about you.
- Yeah, I don't.
- Flip it, no, no, listen, I'm listening.
I'm listening to you, Shawn, you said,
"hey, follow me so I could be
more motivated to go harder."
You're making it selfish.
You wanna pro be selfless.
- Selfless, okay, yeah yeah.
- That is where everyone gets caught.
This is why you won't,
you may win the flip game
but you will not win the
social media content game
because I'm listening
to you, I am listening.
I'm trying to help you right now.
This isn't about come follow
me make my self esteem
up at 1000 I can flex.
This is about how do I
bring them the most value?
This team with Garyvee for
this hour do kind of money
Could be making or doing
things that I need to be doing
in this hour, this isn't
about watch my show.
When I say share, share,
share, I'm not looking
for more fucking followers.
I'm looking to impact more
people's lives so that Shawn,
stumbles upon me and goes
from $50 in his bank account
to 10K a fucking month.
- Yeah, facts,
- Facts make it about that, bro.
You wanna be like me?
Make it about them not about you.
- Okay, yeah.
- I promise cause right now its about you.
That's okay, Cause that's the old Shawn
that had 50 bucks too
and then he heard Garyvee
and he fucking went.
Now you're here together with me.
I hope you hear me make it about them.
- Yeah, I really, in the end like
I really just wanna help people, man.
- No, no, you're still too early to put me
to fully believe that.
You still need too much for you.
And that's okay.
- That's fair.
- It is fair cause it's true
cause I'm listening to you
and I'm watching you, but that's okay.
But make it about them if you wanna grow.
- Okay, yeah.
- Good man, I wish you well.
- All right, see you.
- Talk to you.
Dustin.
- Yeah (chuckles).
- $50 in bank account, to 10,000 a month.
- Yeah, that's, when he
said that I was crazy.
- Bro, You can make 10,000
a month on Pokemon cards
if you get fucking serious here.
You're laughing I'm being
dead fucking serious.
- No, I know but,
- You Pokemons 25th anniversary next year.
- Yeah, that's true, yeah I know.
- You know how hot they're gonna be?
well you need to do is you
need to buy one for 300
sell it for 600 you don't
have the bankroll that I have.
So you have to leave
some money on the table.
You have to buy a card for
300 sell in a month for 600
by doing homework, picking the
right one, it's going to suck
cause I've seen cards
can be 2000 in a year,
but you don't have the
depth of a bank account.
So you need to just keep
flipping so that in six months
you have 30,000 in
profit, then you go ham,
then that 30 becomes 100
do you see where I'm going?
The biggest problem for people right now
is they're like fuck, this
is gonna keep going up.
But they don't have the bank.
You don't have enough liquid.
- Yeah.
- So you need to buy sell, buy,
this is what I did as a kid.
Now, I've worked my fucking
face off for 25 years.
Time to luxury of like, really going in
and not having to flip and maximizing.
But as a kid, I would buy Ken
Griffey for two bucks sell
for three bucks even though
I know it was going to five.
You gotta buy a Squirtle flip it
and then buy something
else that you think is
like there's so many things
that people haven't figured out
like there's Pokemon shares
are right now will go up
but there's cards right now
that people haven't figured
out or under priced.
You have to get deep
into that world be like,
"wait a minute, the base
cards or the trainer cards
"are actually under priced."
You see what I mean?
- Yeah.
- That's how you win that's
sitting with your collection
and looking at it.
- Right, very good point.
- Thank you.
- I mean, I'm always I'm still doing a lot
of like researching, just
watching YouTube videos
of people like the experts doing it.
- So much free content out there.
- Yeah.
- You know, Yoshi sports
cards are not popular
in India, yet, Soccer cards
will be Yoshi Pokemon will be
maybe not American
football, basketball maybe?
And maybe never and that's okay.
Buy them and ship them
to people in America.
I'm buying shit from all over the place.
You know what I haven't gotten
into yet that I'd like to
is Magic the Gathering.
Big shout out to Robbie Turnock.
My best friend as a child.
He, was right on magic the first year.
I was like "what this nerd shit."
- Yeah, I thought the same (laughs)
- Love it bro, its real.
All right, let's keep going.
- Gary what's going on brother?
- What's going on is that you have
a more professional mic than
me and everybody keeps yelling
at me, and I don't give a fuck
that's what's going on, Sean.
- I have it all set, I had it all set up.
I figured I'd use it.
But thanks for thanks
for that, your time, man.
I wanted to give you a
little background of my life.
My brother and sister died when I was 15
about 11 years later.
- I apologize, I'm so sorry to
ask but like tragic accident?
- Yeah, at Thanksgiving 99 they
died in a car accident, yep.
- I am so sorry.
But yeah, I mean, we
always talk about it man.
I mean, the pain learning from
your pain and your struggle.
- How old were you, and how old were they?
- I was 15, my sister is
21 and my brother was 18.
- I'm so sorry my friend.
- I appreciate it, I appreciate it, man.
But it fast forward 11 years
I had a terrible divorce.
I have two kids, I ended up getting
a prescribed pain pills hooked on heroin.
I was basically at the
point of being homeless,
got arrested for stealing out of jail,
from jail to short term
rehab, long term rehab,
and then I was actually
still in my long term rehab
out on passes when I started a podcast,
centered around mental health,
mental health and addiction.
- Why did you start a podcast,
what inspired you to do that?
- Every night, Room 9 which
is the name of my company,
I was in room nine, my long
term treatment facility.
And my roommate and I,
we were always just talking about life,
how are we gonna get better?
How are we gonna fix our shit?
How are we gonna get our shit together?
And so I was like, dude,
we should start a podcast.
And that's what we did.
And so fast forward a
little bit even further.
Now it's going on two years,
I think I got over 90 episodes
now every Monday 10 am.
And I've got a grant from New York State,
a small grant to start video production.
And so I kind of moved into that.
And my main goal is to
really get stories together
of people who have
struggled with mental health
and addiction, and how
they've struggled with it,
how they overcame it,
and really kind of just get a collection
of those stories together.
- I am proud man, I really admire you.
- I appreciate, yeah my life,
all my social life has gone now.
I'm just trying to learn
the Premier Pro after
for everything, getting to
illustrator, graphic design
and really trying to put
all the pieces together.
But my I guess I've been on
this waiting list to talk
to you for three weeks now.
And I'm not even the same
person I was three weeks ago
just from what I've learned and everything
and so my question like, what
am I gonna ask this dude?
Has changed a bunch of
times I mean I know,
yeah and I know you mean,
you talk about patience man
and patience with time,
patience with everything.
Your relationship with failure.
I think that's something
I really wanna push out
to a lot of people's if you
can open your eyes amongst pain
you can change your entire life.
I mean, you can learn
so much in that darkness
and I think that's something
I really wanna push out.
But my guess my question
to you getting to it is
I really have fallen in
love with brand strategy
and really like alright what
is a person's gut feeling
when they think about my company?
- Yes.
- And I just kind of I
found I've been able to take
my shittiness from diction, my Connie
and my talking with people convincing them
and using that in a positive powerful way.
- Shawn, they're kissing cousins,
my mom and dad literally every day.
Like, every day I'm
around them say "my God,
"if you ended up being
bad instead of so good,
"you would have been the
worst human of all time."
Like literally, like, they
compare me to like some
of the worst people of all time.
I actually sometimes,
I'm not a praying man.
But sometimes I literally look up
because I know I have such
talent to communicate.
And I just say thank you God,
for not letting me be selfish and bad,
because I would have fucked this world.
- Yes.
- When I hear you say that
I get it so much, brother.
I get it, so by the way,
it's such a gift and a power
that I feel like I feel
this is a meta moment.
I can't control the fact
that I had to like live
the Garyvee life.
I have to give love, it's
almost like I'm being forced
to buy my chemicals,
because I'm so capable
of communicating things
in a way that almost every
other human doesn't have that ability.
- Yeah.
- Your exactly right.
All those abilities you had on the bad,
they're equally you just flip the coin.
You were on tails, bro, you were on tails.
And thank God that you had
the strength to flip it.
And now you're on heads and
it's gonna fucking work.
I wanna listen to your podcast.
I don't wanna listen to shit.
- (laughs) that'd be great,
you should actually come on sometime.
- How about this, it's done am on.
- Awesome, beautiful.
- Talk to whoever you've talked
to on this and I'll be on
in August, it's locked in.
- Beautiful, I love it.
- And reason I'm doing it is cause I know
that if you have me on
that you could then cold
email everybody on earth
and say Gary Vaynerchuk was on
and you're gonna get a lot of yeses.
I'm giving, I don't have
fucking half hour to be
on your fucking show, Sean.
But I'm forced, I'm forced
out of my gratitude to do it.
I'm being dead fucking serious.
- Absolutely, I know you're
busy as fuck, man, trust me.
I appreciate that greatly.
- Maybe enough to not give.
- I appreciate it, I think
that such an important message
you give to so many
people, that it is it's all
about giving and that's
why I love branding
as opposed to advertising
because branding is about
"hey, give, give, give,"
and pulls pull you in.
And that's why I've kind
of totally fallen in love.
- Did you read "Jab,
Jab, Jab, Right Hook?"
- I have not yet no.
- Dustin can we send this guy
"Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook?"
All right, that's on the way.
- Beautiful, awesome, yeah, man.
Well, I appreciate your time dude.
- Have you got into sports
cards yet, or Pokemon?
I have not gotten into any sports cards.
Funny you talked about coins
and no kids like my 13-year old
loves collecting coins.
- I love that, big shout
out the 13 year old sorry,
I wasn't brazing, I didn't, that's cool.
Did you bro, did you
collect when you were kid
any of that stuff?
- I did actually.
- Yes, show me Sean, show me.
- These are nothing but I just
found these in the basement.
If you remember these and to
disappoint you I'm from Buffalo
by the way, These pro sets,
do you remember these?
- Of course I ungodly
amount of Pro Set hockey.
I had so many and then
before that there was score.
I had so many score Eric
Lindros rookie cards
you can imagine.
- Yeah (laughs).
- And by way, even
though I hate the Bills,
I secretly have a lot of
respect for Sabres fans.
That's been I like
franchises that don't win.
- That's Buffalo.
- And then have good good fans.
I have a lot of respect
for Buffalo secretly.
I can't like the Bills,
because they beat the fuck
out of the Jets in the 80s you went
to for fucking Super Bowls in a row.
But, listen, brother, I love your energy.
I'm so proud of you, keep fighting I know.
Listen, unfortunately,
humans are undereducated on addiction.
This is not something you've won.
This is something you battle daily,
and I have a lot of respect for you.
And I really am excited to
come on Room9Podcast.com.
And I'll see you in a little bit
and I'm just glad you're here.
I'm glad you're here in the
macro, you know what I mean?
- Absolutely, I appreciate
it, I'm glad to be here.
It was it was a switch flip.
- Wait did we answer the question?
Or we just hanging out?
Is there a question?
- That kind of I talked, I
was asking you about branding?
Let me, use branding.
It's about what I just
said to Shawn earlier.
It's about them, not you.
It's about listening, you
know everyone's so confused.
I interrupt people the snap,
like you're always talking fucking loud.
I'd love to hear your fucking own voice.
No I don't fucking listen 24 hours a day.
And then once in a while,
have a moment to talk.
I'm fucking listening
24 hours a day, Sean.
I'm reading more comments,
more DMs, more emails,
more texts from my community
than any fucker on Earth.
I'm so busy that I'm not
replying like I used to.
But I haven't stopped listening at all.
I'm fucking hearing you.
It's how I bring up my content.
It's how it goes.
Branding and marketing
is about the customer,
not about your selfish wants and needs.
That's why fortune 500 companies struggle.
That's why VaynerMedia
has helped them so much.
And that's why so many influencers suck.
And that's why I'm helping them so much.
And that's what you need to focus on.
- Awesome, well, I appreciate it, brother.
And for it really, really
quick for anybody out there.
It just, it was a switch for me.
It just happened where I
just started loving myself
and if you don't take care of yourself
and love yourself and have
confidence in yourself
and have confidence to fail,
I mean that's the biggest thing.
- It's because everybody else sucks, too.
- Yeah, we all stuck.
- Listen brother, you went
through a super painful thing.
I don't know what kind
of person you were at 15
if that was inevitable
that you were gonna go down
a tough path because of the chemicals
because of the parenting.
But fuck, bro to go through
that kind of tragedy,
that's a shock.
- No, it is, yeah, and
I didn't even realize
how much it fucked me up
until probably a decade later.
- Of course because whatever, again,
we I'm running out of time
I gotta to run to a client,
but maybe you were tryna
be strong for your parents.
I don't know your circumstance,
but it's the subconscious that takes over.
- Yep, absolutely, all right Gary, well,
I'll let you get going, brother.
I appreciate your time and
you're the best, piece.
Man I saw the comments,
big shout out to you.
Way to fight through that meth.
Thank you, Sean, I love everybody.
I hope everybody's super well.
I love you see you tomorrow
or am I tomorrow, Dustin?
- Yep.
- Oh, all right.
- No Friday though, just tomorrow.
- See you tomorrow, everybody.
Please, please, please
let's get a fuck load
of people watching this shit.
We're helping out here, see ya.